on a beau avoir des idées lumineuses
comment les gouvernements peuvent-ils
aider les entreprises à innover et
conquérir de nouveaux marchés
l'une des formules qui a été retenu au
cours des dernières décennies a été de
réduire le taux d'imposition des
sociétés en espérant qu'elles
réinvestissent ces sommes dans leur
expansion
est ce là une recette gagnante mieux
faire confiance aux dernières tendances
voilà le risque que court fréquemment
les investisseurs ont couvé roi à jerry
cros et paul cros jerry fait découvrir
son dernier investissement à son amie
une petite entreprise qui a conçu une
voiture électrique à trois roues dont
les premiers modèles seront livrés aux
acheteurs l'hiver prochain depuis 25 ans
qu'il côtoie le monde des affaires comme
témoin actif
ils ont vu les tournées position des
entreprises canadiennes fondre comme
neige au soleil
dans le cas des petites entreprises joe
rick roll constate que le taux 11%
depuis 2008 est très avantageux mais il
ne croit pas pour autant que cela soit
le principal facteur qui cite les
canadiens se lancer en affaires dans
jéricho que son ami investisseurs
pot-aux-roses croit tout de même que
l'impôt doit être attrayant que ce soit
pour les petites ou les grandes
entreprises c'est important d'avoir les
justin de démo qui est compétitif
de façon globale et puis tout à travers
du monde on a vu des ces peaux ternes
pas de passer alors canada rester bon
compétitif dans ce cas là dans le
palmarès des taux d'imposition des pays
les plus industrialisés le canada fait
bonne figure des 34 pays de l'osce et
des yeux il est parmi ceux qui ont le
plus faible taux d'imposition fédéral
pour les grandes sociétés à 15%
ce la suisse et l'irlande ont des taux
inférieurs si on ajoute les impôts
provinciaux le canada se situe dans la
moyenne des pays de l'osce et des oeufs
on n'a pas du tout assisté à ce boom
d'investissement construite est éric
pineault l'institut de recherche et
d'informations socio-économiques un
organisme camper à gauche rappelle que
les gouvernements fédéraux d'abord
libéral puis conservateurs ont depuis 15
ans presque réduit de moitié le taux
d'imposition des entreprises
en espérant qu'elle réinvestirait dans
l'économie cela ne s'est pas produit
inutile sauf dans le secteur pétrolier
c'est pour ça qu'il va mener une
entreprise investisse approbation les
pots en entreprise on investir s'il ya
des perspectives de croissance qui se
présentent si la demande pour ses
produits présentés et on joue pas sur
ces indicateurs à la province les pots
d'entreprise mais une entreprise qu'est
ce qu'elle fait un peu pâle investir
activement donc elles vont attendre
l'occasion donc avoir épargné alors les
baisses d'impôts se sont traduits par
l'accumulation des palmes d épargne si
énorme on les évalue et l'an dernier à
plus de 640 milliards de dollars que
même un ancien gouverneur de la banque
du canada a souligné le fait que de
telles sommes dormait dans les coffres
alors que l'économie aurait bien besoin
d'investissements le montant des
liquidités des entreprises canadiennes a
explosé au cours des 25 dernières années
on le sait bien l'économie mondiale a
connu des hauts et des bas ces dernières
années on l'a senti en europe et aux
états unis puis maintenant en chine
c'est pour être certaine de pouvoir
naviguer dans ces eaux troubles que les
grandes entreprises disent mettre de
l'argent de côté des sommes d'argent
maintenant à leur disposition pour faire
des investissements mais encore faut-il
que du côté de la clientèle dont des
marchés vers lequel évidemment nos
produits et services doivent être vendus
il faut que les opportunités sera fermé
ce actuellement on est encore dans une
grande instabilité on le voit d'ailleurs
dans les marchés boursiers
à vancouver les hommes d'affaires jerry
krause et port cros regarde vers
l'avenir il espère que cette voiture se
popularise sur les routes
il souhaite aussi une économie forte
pour le canada et selon pas au chorus la
solution ne passe pas uniquement par des
baisses d'impôts
l'investissement dans l'innovation à
aller les investissements dans les
hôtels et bien-être pour que les
personnes qui travaillent peuvent être
se cure dent pour leurs familles et
leurs enfants on est des opportunités et
même si on a ici un environnement qui
est qui et des sables et bien
confortable la séoune opportunités
commence à pourrir
vraiment créer des emplois de nouvelles
entreprises comme ça